arguably the primary source of all fear
sorrow and existential conflict is the
self-awareness and foresight of our
mortality the fact that we can live a
life that feels so real so important and
so incredible that we are compelled to
want it to go on forever
the fact that we can speculate and
comprehend the possibility of the
infinite yet be forced to live with the
realization that we are finite and
everything we do and care about is
subject to the short timeline of our
life at some point everything will
evaporate away into nothingness as
humans this is our curse we are the seam
between the infinite and the finite able
to ponder and longed for the eternal yet
be bound to the impermanence of our
deteriorating body but perhaps in some
strange puzzling way this is also our
blessing currently we cannot control the
biology of our human organism we cannot
control the fact that we live inside of
a decomposing carbon-based body destined
for expiration but we can control at
least to some degree the way we view and
think about things from within it and so
we can control how we think about the
idea of our death and rationalize with
it in a way that reduces some of its
torment and allows us to make the best
of our life before it arrives in order
to do so consider a video game board
game or sports game that you have played
in the past what was the driving force
of playing said game
certainly you enjoyed playing the game
for itself but you were ultimately
planned toward something you were
playing the game towards and end point
and arguably you only played the game
because you knew there would be an end
point the human mind is seemingly fixed
on requiring an end point to derive
meaning and motivation for doing things
what would again be without an end would
we even play
what would a story be without a
conclusion everything we construct and
do in life whether intentional or not
has an end point death is life's end
point these our motivation to play the
game of life and to create our narrative
within it without it we would not care
to leave legacies through our careers
passions and Families we would not want
to positively impact the world around us
we would not be inspired to create
fascinating art develop exciting
technology and incite innovative ways of
thinking and we would not work to make
the best out of life and find Wonder in
all its simple pleasures to live with
the knowledge and angst of our impending
mortality is undoubtedly the curse of
humankind but it is paradoxically our
blessing in disguise
perhaps our brains cannot discern
meaningful existence without an end
point ironically death is the reason why
we cherish life so deeply and it is
because we cherish life so deeply that
we fear death with such great intensity
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder